welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a breakdown of episode
six of what if where black panther fans
everywhere are given the treat of the
return of michael b jordan's killmonger
to the mcu in a scenario where
killmonger was the one to save tony
stark in afghanistan rather than tony
being saved by a box of scraps you know
like a normal person but let us go ahead
and get into all those neat little
easter eggs and things that you could
have missed from this iron man ass black
panther crossover episode shall we my
beautiful nerd babies i think we shall
and right off the bat we start off the
episode with ua to the watchers stating
every journey has a beginning in jeffrey
wright's deeply mysterious sultry voice
that his mama gave him before we watch
the watcher watch over the very
beginnings of our journey through the
mcu through the recreation of the very
same opening shots from iron man 1 from
right before tony stark's military
convoy is attacked in the kunar province
of afghanistan with a few exceptions
here and there like how the soldier
named jimmy who asks tony for a picture
holds up a camera in what if but in the
movie he doesn't grab his camera until
after tony says it's okay and also how
the bullet holes that end up murdering
poor soldier jimmy shortly after are
slightly different than in live action
like it has a different spread and you
know i've got to say it but there is a
glaringly apparent lack of both ac dc's
back in black and references to
myspace.com like we got in the live
action movie which is rude tom was your
friend too marvel tom was your friend
too and after tony does a skedaddle out
of the convoy we do notice that animated
tony uses a flip phone while rdj kept
that mother
sidekick fang on him because how else is
he going to replace terence howard
rhodey with don cheadle roadie and his
myspace top 5 exactly there's no other
way good god iron man 1 is basically a
period piece now and then this leads us
to our major nexus event of the episode
eric killmonger eaten the missile that
would have embedded shrapnel into tony
stark's body forcing tony to develop a
miniaturized arc reactor and the first
iron man suit to save his own life and
killmonger's theme music for the black
panther score plays in the background
while killmonger shoots and murders a
ton of off-screen ten rings terrorists
like this had aimbot installed in
his cranium and i think that these
animated movements could have been an
intentional callback to that time where
everett ross describes killmonger's time
in afghanistan in black panther 1.
joined the seals and went straight to
afghanistan where he wrapped up
confirmed kills like it was a video game
and i do really dig this quick shot of
tony grasping killmonger's wrist as he
helps him up because i believe that this
shot is supposed to reflect a spartan
handshake you know to represent the new
alliance bond that these two now have
together and i also really love how we
get to see killmonger say that his name
is a nickname in afghanistan after
everett ross alluded to him getting the
nickname in afghanistan in black panther
one so it's cool to see that period when
that name is like fresh because he just
got it and after the watcher watches the
beginnings of this very unfortunate new
relationship we get animated shots of
the three most iconic moments of tony
stark's journey as a hero in you know
the good universe the forging of the
first iron man mask of the cave the
formation of the avengers in new york
and finally his final sacrifice in
avengers endgame and i especially love
how when watu says the word forge that
we do get the shot of animated tony
forging his suit however in this
instance when he's banging on the box of
scrappy masks in what if i did notice
that tony's box of scrappy reactor in
his chest glows a lot brighter and wider
than robert downey jr's more subtle
reactor in the movie and also this
animated tony doesn't seem to have the
glow of a fire source coming from the
right side of the frame like rdj does in
the movie and also while the iconic
avengers pan from the movie of course
starts off with hulk screaming at us at
the camera in avengers 1 here we see it
start with iron man before the hulk
screams so like we kind of get like a
couple seconds before
that iconic shot with iron man starting
it off and also also when animated end
game tony snaps there's a lot more delay
before the screen goes to white than
there is in end game but anyways moving
on when tony begins his press conference
he notes that the drink that he was
holding on a convoy was actually a
macallan whiskey from the year 1926 a
bottle of which in the real world
recently sold for a whopping
1.2 million dollars so yeah i would be
kind of upset too just one glass of that
alcohol juice is worth more than my
entire life but anyways after tony
announces killmonger as his new chief
security officer for stark industries a
job that was originally given to happy
hogan in our timeline in iron man 3
which is why we see an unhappy hogan
here christine everhart the very same
reporter that tony stark spends a night
with at the very beginning of the first
iron man film is the one to ask what
exactly eric killmonger was doing in
afghanistan in the first place with
actress leslie bibb reprising her role
as christine but not reprising their
role for this episode is jeff bridges as
obadish stain with the voice actor kif
van duvel doing a pretty damn good
impression instead like he does a
fantastic job at capturing the
exaggerated swagger of a greedy
corporate executive who just got caught
trying to assassinate the head of a
major weapons company that jeff bridges
just perfected in that role like that
exaggerated swagger just hard to
replicate with a box of scraps and i
freaking love this monger match up here
with the killmonger having taken down
the ironmonger by dropping olive stains
tan rings tea online black widow style
you know because black widow did at the
end of winter soldier like a boss
t eric procured during his time
undercover in the ten rings and all of
this while the heartbeat-like thud of
ludwig granson's killmonger theme plays
in the background yet again and i
literally cannot get enough of that
because ludwig granson is the man son
but anyways after tony stark says a
wildly inappropriate sex joke about
maxum models coming for the king on
thedisneyman.com tony stark offers
killmonger obadiah's job that tony
originally does gift to pepper in iron
man 2 and says you me will be like butch
in sundance which is of course a
reference to the movie butch cassidy and
the sundance kid starring hydra's very
own robert redford which is like another
instance in the mcu where tony stark
mentions a movie where a co-star of his
also started you know like that time
tony stark mentioned the big lebowski in
the end game and all this then leads us
to seeing pepper have a chat with don
cheadle's james rhode marking the second
time what if has inserted an mcu recast
into their acting predecessor's mcu time
period with the first instance being
mark ruffalo's hulk replacing edward
norton's hulk in episode 3 of what if
and later when tony and killmonger hang
out in tony's iron man 1 garage
killmonger picks up a portable version
of the jericho missile that tony stark
was apparently working on even before he
originally demonstrated the real thing
in afghanistan and like the design of it
kind of reminds me of how shield
miniaturized the asgardian destroyer
armor in avengers 1. you know the same
gun that coulson shoots loki with before
he dies like a badass if i'm going to go
i want to go shooting an asgardian
and then shortly after
killmonger quotes howard stark's lying
peace means having a bigger stick than
the other guy my old man had a
philosophy peace means having a bigger
stick than the other guy and when eric
tells tony that his dad was killed by
gang violence we already know that
michael b lyon because we already done
saint his dad get murdered by king
t'chaka in black panther 1 and
killmonger knew that his father was
murdered by panther claws i found my
daddy with panther claws in his chest
and here at new rockstars we're fans of
learning whether it's about branch
timelines or chemical reactions it's fun
to learn more about both the fantastical
and real world and brilliant has been a
great way for us to do just that a
brilliant way some would say
and thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring this video brilliant is an
educational service that replaces
typical lecture videos with hands-on
interactive lessons and it's a better
and more fun way to learn and they have
a really cool scientific thinking course
check out this lesson on optics and in
it you can move around an individual
beam of light reflecting off of a gem in
a box of mirrors to see the path that
light takes to get to your eye it's a
great way to get started on learning the
law of reflection it's really cool and
brilliant is here to inspire people to
actively play with the ideas of math and
science the lessons are interactive and
interesting with quizzes and activities
that bring the topics to life and
brilliant offers masterfully designed
courses that help you to conquer all
sorts of technical subjects once i'm
done with the scientific thinking course
i'm eyeballing the physics course
because your boy can't stop learning i
just i love to learn and brilliant has
courses in applied science number theory
quantum computing and all sorts of other
stem topics so you got all sorts of
things there so to support the channel
and learn more about brilliant go to
brilliant.org new rockstars and sign up
for free and the first 200 people that
go to the link will get 20 off the
annual premium subscription so try
brilliant today and also can we please
talk about how tony already had access
to mit's doctoral thesis database when
pulling up killmonger's plans for the
liberator mix because this definitely
feels like both a reference to tony
stark's affinity for mit that we see in
civil war but it also makes me feel that
maybe just maybe we'll find out that
tony stark was well aware of ruby
williams genius before he passed away in
endgame when we see riri at mit in
wakanda forever and her iron heart
series i'm starting to get this weird
vibe that tony has been looking for
protege this entire time which is why
he's so readily accepting killmonger as
his like pseudo-son because peter parker
at this age he's just a young boy like
we haven't seen him yet in iron man 2
about to get shot by those hammer drums
but anyways moving on this anime gundam
inspired design of eric's wakanda
liberating liberators was 100 inspired
by actor michael b jordan's deep love
for the anime medium you know much like
the design for killmonger's entire
outfit in black panther was revealed to
have been designed with vegeta from
dragon ball z in mind because us weebs
are taking over the world
which then kicks us off into a building
montage with tony and eric akin to the
montage that we get in iron man 1 when
tony was first building his mark ii
armor but before this tony does mention
fpv wiring nano circuitry and bloody
mary's hangover's starting to kick in
which kind of makes you see the wonders
being a hero has done for robert johnny
junior's tony's alcoholism problem which
is of course something the character has
historically struggled with a lot more
in the comics but in this universe tony
seems to drink a lot more than we ever
see him drink in the mcu like he
literally drops a glass of whiskey as
he's dying but anyways while tony and
eric are thinking of power sources for
the mechs eventually deciding on
vibranium much like ultron did in age of
ultron with his vibranium core for
sokovia it kinda reminds me of that shot
of tony nat and bruce planning the new
york time heist together and i was also
cracking up when tony almost had the
idea for a mini arc reactor if we could
miniaturize an arc reactor
oh that's a dumb idea but anyways tony
eventually recruits the help of ulysses
claw the notorious black panther villain
with a killer sound system for an arm
that was originally introduced in age of
ultron and that's when tony says that he
met claw at a weapons conference in the
past where he found out about claw's
interest in this hot new african rock
that all the kids are talking about it's
gonna be all the rage so this 2008 tony
reaching out to claw makes a lot of
sense and also the office where the
three talk about claw is a recreation of
tony's office from iron man one which is
pretty fun but anyways when roadie meets
up with claw to make a deal at claw's
same south african salvage shipyard from
age of ultron club managed to procure a
steer from one of wakanda's dora melange
which apparently are worth 10 million
dollars a pop so needless to say johnny
mayonnaise experienced the world's most
expensive ass beating in falcon in the
winter soldier god damn but anyway
speaking of ass beatings t'challa of
course gave a whole helping to claws
unfortunate partners in crime from the
shadows hearkening back to that initial
stealth scene of t'challa stalking that
convoy in the jungle in black panther
but unfortunately as deadly as t'challa
was both him and his mcu brother were
killed by the hand of another mcu
brother a hand that was holding a new
version of the stark industries sonic
taser that if you remember from iron man
1 was used by obadiah stain on more than
one occasion like i'm actually starting
to wonder if ulysses claws arm in the
mcu is based off of this sonic taser
technology and also t'challa dying by
the hands of a sonic weapon at claws
place is definitely an illusion towards
t'challa's many dealings with the sonic
powered claw in the comics because in
the comics claw is essentially black
panther's joker like that is his nemesis
but anyways moving on when t'challa's
body is being escorted by the dora
milaje the words wakanda forever can be
seen written on his casket in the native
wakandan language which of course serves
as a soft tribute to the late chadwick
boseman but anyways when tony is
confronting killmonger about the murder
of his best friend rhodey he pulls up a
holographic model of the murder scene if
you remember tony also does this in iron
man 3 when he recreates the sights of
all the mandarin bombings to play
detective but something i find really
interesting after eric kills tony is the
relationship between killmonger and
general ross because it kind of seems to
mirror the relationship that t'challa
had with his military ross because he
had everett ross and now killmonger has
ross not as fun as everett ever
it's a nice guy so many wakandan
shenanigans to be done with the white
ross let me tell you grab a white ross
today but anyways when killmonger and
claw arrive at wakanda's doorstep the
last thing claw learns before he is shot
is that he's been working with a
wakandan this entire time the same
economist that he thinks are savages
savages and this is a lot like he did in
the movie which i thought was a nice
touch you savages didn't deserve it
however unlike the movie this killmonger
reveals his wakandan lip tattoo outside
as he approaches wakanda whereas in the
movie we don't get to see that michael b
bottom lip until eric kills claw but
anyway shortly after this we find out
the bad ass black panther fact that
angela bassett's queen ramonda was a
freaking general of the wakandan army
which makes a lot of sense considering
that the wakandan army is pretty much
female dominated and i very much love
how both the king and queen of wakanda
aren't afraid to get their hands dirty
when they have to like they're kind of
like odin and frigga in that way and
when killmonger's liberators finally
breach through wakanda's barriers to
liberate wakanda from eric's family we
get to see the world's reaction to
discovering the true opulence of wakanda
for the very first time through the eyes
of general ross undoubtedly giving this
universe's wakanda even more
geopolitical enemies because everyone
wants that sweet ass vibranium and no
one's gonna like finding out that this
african nation is the most powerful and
most technologically advanced nation in
the world and after that crazy final
battle that ends with yet another subtle
tearful tribute to t'challa and chadwick
boseman by queen ramonda we have
killmonger and t'chaka enjoying a
wakandan sunset together in the same way
that him and t'challa did in black
panther but this time with killmonger on
his feet in victory rather than on his
knees in defeat and there he would of
course trick his uncle into making him
the next black panther but instead of
seeing his father in the ancestral plane
killmonger has a contentious
conversation with his cousin t'challa
instead and man i don't know about you
but seeing chadwick boseman as a panther
on that panther tree hit me where i live
man because it's really wild to think
that chadwick recorded this scene while
going through all that pain that he was
going through himself so rest in peace
chadwick postman we really appreciate
everything that you've done and of
course the episode ends with shuri and
pepper the only smart people in this
universe apparently meeting up to
potentially do something about their
killmonger problem but not before ross
notes that they're ready to launch a
bunch of tony's crazy powerful jericho
missiles at wakanda i'm not sure what's
gonna happen next but it's for sure
going to be some messy though i do
secretly hope that shuri and pepper team
up to make wakandan iron man suits
because let's be real making an iron man
suit kind of science fair-ass for
sure and iron man suits do not exist in
this universe so it'd be really cool to
see shuri come up with the idea for the
iron man concept but yeah that is it for
our breakdown for episode 6 of what if
what did you guys think of the episode
let us know in the comment section below
my nerd babies but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
can follow me mastertainment on twitter
if you want to see me tweet some weird
but most importantly please follow
new rockstars on twitter and youtube and
when you do on youtube make sure to hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications whenever we upload a video
please go to newrockstarsmerch.com to
pick up our really awesome shirts like
the shanxi morris shirt that everyone is
really digging everyone's really loving
it so pick one up today before it
disappears forever alright thank you so
much for watching and i will see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
you